smilla hamdullah assalamualaikum i'm
with sheikh muhammad from the Kean
Institute a research fellow how are you
[ __ ]
thank you I know it was kind of last
minute but we got some of this news and
we wanted just to quickly go ahead and
discuss it
on this far-right politician who
accepted Islam he was Arthur Wagner he's
from a leading far-right political party
in Germany
what were your what was your first
reaction when you when you heard this
I mean overjoyed for him amazed at the
circumstance right what direction is
coming from but also the fact that this
is obviously a person when you think
about it and how it came about this is a
man of great integrity our word somehow
reaching this is a testimony that we
must recognize his integrity to his
moral fortitude not just because he
chose Islam but just in general just if
anyone were to put themselves in his
shoes like many people don't realize the
magnitude of that decision for a person
especially in his position you know it
even reminds me of a statement of the
Prophet peace and blessings be upon him
that's two hungry wolves let loose on a
flock of sheep will not do more damage
to that flock of sheep than the love of
wealth and the love of reputation will
do damage someone's religious commitment
so he had to be at odds with potentially
his income and his reputation both
combine to walk away from a platform
that was anchored in this right an
antagonist of Islam and become a Muslim
himself and so if that's not a testimony
to his character may Allah make him even
above what we expect of him an increase
in strength and knowledge and sincerity
and accept from him is Islam
it says here that he was also very
active in the Christian wing of the
party what are your thoughts when you
when you hear that also I mean
there's already a common ground I mean
many people that have a judeo-christian
background many at times they simply
just may not know in whatever sphere or
bubble a person grows up in that we have
many of the same roots theologically in
terms of we believe in heavenly
scripture we believe in prophethood what
do you mean you must believe in Jesus
what do you believe about them no no we
love Him we emulates him and so perhaps
that was a bit of what warmed him over
to slam I'd love to explore more but I
know that he resigned to the fact that
it's a private matter and he will not
discuss it at least at this point in
time but that would be my guess
their slogan was Islam does not belong
in Germany right and then to see someone
you know like many what what I've seen
in probably yourself is that many of
them they haven't really sincerely
looked at Islam they haven't even
connected with Muslim but he started to
do some some some connecting with
Muslims and I'm sure from there he
started to probably look into Salaam or
assuming but it's a totally different
thing now when you actually take the
time out you're sincere you're genuine
and like you said there's so many
commonalities Christians would have like
our love for for Jesus peace be upon him
and so the honest God works in
mysterious ways
indeed we believe that as Muslims
mysteriously beautiful ways they're
mysterious to us but we're certain that
they're beautiful if you think of how
the circumstances are set up for our
brother Arthur Wagner like in this case
he was working with immigrants and
refugees so God set up for him a
scenario that could allow them to
experience firsthand Muslims as well
something to shatter perhaps his
prejudice and it and it pushed him to
take a stand against what he wants stood
for and make up for what has passed you
know it's Allah guides whom He wills
right Islam is something by invitation
only and so he was invited into a
scenario that allowed for this
and this is the Koran I love the most
Isis with our ally Malathi him clear on
that smile
if Allah knows it was good in someone he
will allow them a chance to hear it out
to hear the message he'll set that up
for them you know here in the United
States according to the Pew Research
Center I came across these numbers about
two days ago
that converts to Islam offsets the
numbers of people leaving Islam as a
result of the dump and narrative of
secular liberalism I guess and atheism
and so 23 percent versus 23 percent it
reminds you what the Quran tells us that
God replaces one people with another
sometimes that nobody's inherently
entitled to guidance like how come they
get born to a Muslim family how can God
wanted that we know they're just as many
people coming in as people going out and
that's why it wouldn't be fair otherwise
like that's what you don't find Sam just
in a particular ethnic city or in a
particular income strata or in a
particular IQ range no God invites to
hear this message those that he knows
good about what what do you think people
from his party people who come across us
talking you know who are really struck
in awe because of this what should they
take from this from him
you know they know what kind of person
he was what he stands for you know he's
an intelligent human being from him
making this crucial decision in his life
what do you think they should take away
from this right and in all honesty this
for many of them should be a moment of
truth a moment for them to give
themselves pause and look at themselves
in the mirror and be brave enough to see
past their biases regarding some of the
Muslims this is someone Arthur Wagner
who you were confident in and his
judgment calls is the stretch one of the
great rabbis of the Jews in the city of
Medina named Sam and when he became
Muslim he feared that he would be
slandered and so he told the Prophet
peace be upon him - don't tell my people
I became Muslim and so when his people
came forward the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him wanted to hold
them to their own value system to their
own convictions where I belong to them
and his credibility and so what he did
first was tell them what do you say what
I am and they said he's the best of us
and most godly of Ostergard regarding
the rabbinical code or regarding the
Torah and the message of Moses he's the
best of us at some of the best of us the
most knowledgeable of us the son of the
most knowledgeable of us and he said
what if he were to become Muslim they
say oh no he would never do something
like that and so at that point among
celebs he says actually I did become
Muslim and so in the same breath they
said no he's the worst of us and the
most ignorant of us to the end of it the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him was trying to make it easy for
them to remind them of what they thought
of him and yet moments later they went
back on their own judgments so this
discredited them didn't discreditable
under Saddam so likewise this is a
moment of truth for many of his party
members to consider the possibility that
knowledge regarding Islam and the
Muslims could have been selectively
pitched to them and that things are not
as they seem maybe it's time to hear
from the Muslims and not about them and
that justice would entail that if we
hold ourselves as people of justice I
mean at the end of the day your party or
no matter what party political party it
is that's not gonna save you on the day
of judgement when you die when this
whole life is over I mean this man
obviously was contemplating probably
what the purpose of life is the message
of Islam is believable it's simple to
understand you know you have an
authentic book the Quran like no other
book in the world it stands the test he
brings you no good for the individual
good for
you know and like you said it's really a
a point in that person's you know his
his friends who have known him for so
long for them to think you know to
ponder but why do you think sometimes a
lot of times the opposite happens and
now some people say well he's he's been
in kind of this kind of the same thing
happened during the Prophet Mohammad's
time he's been bewitched or something's
you know he's lost his scruples
he's yesterday history continues beating
itself we are the same human race the
same tendencies and we are all addressed
by the same message of God you know
before we close though and advice to the
Muslims as well that it may come when it
comes it comes the guidance of Allah
right so many come in a person and from
a direction that you least expected and
so be available with your Aslam be a
parent with your Islam be present with
your Islam be polite but proud with your
Islam you know and someone is going to
say and make the the slogan of their
campaign there's no place for Islam in
Germany your response shouldn't just be
yes there is room for Islam in Germany
and we have apologetic please accept the
sense of the word it should be more
along the lines of yes there is room for
Islam in Germany and there's much in
Islam that has that can offer Germany
that is a great asset for German with
his beliefs and its values so this is a
time for you to truly examine everyone's
talking about it
not to Charlie at this opportunity
obstacle this is you know in the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him and it's all
life lessons and genius and wisdom when
people finally started talking about
Islam three years into his call and
everyone saying wait a minute you heard
about a - you heard about a - you heard
about - what are these Muslims want and
they're slowly increasing it he just
stood up on top of the mountain that
will today when he said listen everybody
if I told you there's an army behind
this mountain about to attack you would
you believe me they said we've never
heard a lot from you he said then know
this that I am the messenger of up to
you before the coming of a great day
before the coming of a grievous
punishment before the Day of
Resurrection a day we all return to God
and stand before him and so whenever
when the conversation is bubbly this is
it slams time to show what it can offer
humanity see in the world and so we
should feel privileged / - it is window
being open for us conclude you've
written a lot of different articles one
in particularly in particular that
understand that comes to mind is one
that you because there's a lot of
misconceptions revolving around
obviously Islam and the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him
you actually wrote I believe it was you
who wrote the article for a yaqeen
Institute which specializes in this also
like Adi show Clara many of these
misconceptions what was the title of it
had to do with Prophet Muhammad and
engagement what was it called this this
one article there is a series of
articles that have been written papers
called the proofs prophethood series so
different aspects or characters that all
are cited as proofs towards leave Iraq
city of this prophethood a piece of
blessing for somebody who's coming as
well for someone for someone who's
interested to learn more about Mohammed
and Islam which one of these articles
would you recommend from the yuckiness
titute that people can go and research
and looking for background and so I
would request of them so busy obtain
institute why AQE and institute.org and
they'll find i guess under my name
laughter series and so if you're coming
from a certain type of background I do
their Christian background maybe the
first piece under the historical truths
might strike more of a chord with you if
you come for example from a more
altruistic but strictly humanistic
perspective if you're an agnostic
testimony of this character being
unparalleled which I believe was the
second paper could be of greater
interest to see the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him we believe was the
final prophet sent to at all of
humankind and so God sent so many proofs
supporting his mission so that it could
be relatable to all of humankind in
terms of time and place and that's why
that response is necessary that
different proofs may crystallize the
reality of him being the messenger of
God for different people something that
you jump in blindly when you're talking
about proofs it doesn't seem like many
religion they say okay this is just
based on faith here you don't believe we
don't have blind faith in it's now we
have blind surrender once you're sure
through the mind that God gave you his
water in the pool then you jump that's
what I'm sure the individual brother who
accepted Islam Arthur Wagner I'm sure
that he being the intelligent person
that he is he looked at the proofs he
connected with Muslims and we urge you
to make the human connection to connect
with us to talk with us any closing
comments and advice for other people who
are looking into this story share before
the conclusion and anyone else was taken
off guard or marveling at this change of
heart he said we would humbly request of
you to find a copy of the Quran and do
yourself that favor of granting yourself
a similar opportunity of connecting with
your creator the creator of the heavens
and the earth the one we came from the
one we prayed for and the one we yearn
for his company in the hereafter forever
thank you very much as okhla hard
thinking sir thank you having a salary
complement
you